les 60000 habitants des îles caïmans se
sont fait une belle frayeur hier quand
la terre s'est mise à bouger
il est 14 heures 10 et beaucoup sont bel
et bien impuissant face à la secousse
aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître ce séisme de magnitude 7,7
survenu en mer est ressentie
simultanément à cuba et en jamaïque n'a
pas provoqué de dégâts majeurs
l'activité a repris aujourd'hui mais la
vigilance reste de mise
on craint les répliques comme celle
d'hier mesurée à 6,1 ou celle de 5,1 qui
s'est produite ce matin peu avant 10
heures par mesure de précaution les
écoles sont restées fermées aujourd'hui
le gouverneur de ce territoire
britannique s'est félicité que le pire
était évité hier était clairement une
journée très difficile pour nous tous
sur l'île je veux dire face à un séisme
de magnitude 7,7 et à la menace d'un
tsunami seraient était un défi pour
n'importe quelle administration dans le
monde
je veux d'abord remercier enfin vous
dire que nous avons de la chance nous
n'avons pas subi de pertes en vies
humaines et les dégâts sont heureusement
très très faible nous avons remis des
îles en marche très rapidement le pont
et l'aéroport fonctionne
nous avons six bateaux de croisière ici
aujourd'hui l'eau a été rétablie et des
vérifications sont en cours
retour à la normale aussi à cuba
même si l'on s'inquiète aussi
d'éventuelles répliques le séisme d'hier
était le plus fort jamais enregistré
depuis que le pays s'est doté d'un
observatoire en 1964 la ville de nick
héros au sud de l'île considéré comme la
zone la plus proche de l'épicentre a
ressenti fortement les effets du séisme
sans entraîner selon les autorités de
conséquences graves sur les
infrastructures socialisme je pense
qu'il a été le plus long que j'ai pu
ressentir de toute ma vie vraiment je me
disais bon lot tremblement de terre va
s'arrêter non non non ça a continué on
l'a ressenti assez fortement mais toutes
les personnes sont sorties de chez elle
en respectant toutes les mesures qu'elle
devait prendre mais bon
si nous sommes toujours dans
l'expectative parce qu'il peut y avoir
une nouvelle réplique et nous devrons
tous être vigilants
une vigilance qui passe avant tout par
des messages de prévention en jamaïque
les autorités n'ont pas hésité à
diffuser très largement leur vidéo sur
les conduites à adopter en cas de
tremblement terre
ah ah